it's been I don't want to send it 20 is
it 18 years ago coming in for this 28
years ago to lose it oh my god I don't
want to say that say 202 years ago
again stop hiding here can you believe
it it's actually been 26 years since
Ilyn stunned audiences but they're
famous Disney duet but when she was
approached to sing on the new film
soundtrack it wasn't an immediate yet I
see the movie it's great but there's
something that's inside of me that's
shaking a little bit to be honest with
you I said to them that it's so hard to
me to commit right now because I was
feeling like cheating with the first
Union disease I went back home I
listened to it I wasn't sure I kind of
talked to Renee and he said you should
and Selene is keeping busy with another
upcoming project the Today Show recently
announced she'll be teaming up with Gwen
Stefani as a key advisor on the upcoming
season of The Voice everybody is going
to be mad the other coaches that I got
you yes oh yes but don't expect her to
take over as a full-time coach my son is
already playing hockey and he asked me
if I can be the coach beside the words
you want me to be the coach I prefer to
be on the couch the singer is expanding
her usual range delving into the fashion
business of handbags called the Celine
Dion collection I want my fans to know
that I would wear my thing so I was very
proud today to come with my own first
hopefully amidst her busy schedule
she'll find time to make it back to
Canada for this year's tuna I'm not
extremely
Dutch because obviously I don't do this
business to be a nomination or to win
awards but this one means a lot to me
because this is my first album that I
reported without my extra food so thank
you so much for the nomination
moon will appreciate
[Music]